we've got had this problem we know
energy bills are very volatile and we
need to actually now see what they're
going to end up at and if there's more
that needs to be done of course I would
do that as I've done over the past two
years let's trust if you are prime
minister would you be doing something
immediately to help people with these
bills well first of all I also want to
pay tribute to David Trimble who was a
political Giant and who secured helped
secure peace in Northern Ireland I would
act immediately I understand that people
here people around the country are
struggling with some of the worst cost
of living problems that we've had for
Generations it's hard to pay for fuel
it's hard to pay for food I would
reverse the increase in National
Insurance we promise not to raise it in
our Manifesto in 2019 the people here
who voted conservative for the first
time expect us to fulfill our promises
well Mr sunak made some interruptions
mistrust made this comment
urgent action the
promise is tomorrow they want things
today to relieve the cost of living but
also to get Spades in the ground in
Stoke-on-Trent and other towns and
cities across our country what I would
do immediately is put in new low tax
investment zones with simplified
planning so we could get on with
building and we could get on with those
new projects I'd keep corporation tax
low to attract investment from around
the world I know how popular uh the you
know the the products produced here
whether it's the pottery or the toffees
or Walker's toffee you know we can Turbo
Charge that but we need to challenge the
Orthodoxy that is making things so slow
to deliver and I know people want things
to happen
urgently I'm somebody in every job I've
done absolutely whether it's the trade
deals I've struck at trade whether what
I've done at the foreign office putting
the toughest sanctions on Russia of any
country I get things done in government
and I don't just talk I act
no holds Barnes uh but Mr sunak
continued with a jab at Ms truss on
inflation
we remember the 80s and the 90s and you
know what the problem we had then it was
inflation and it's a problem that we
have now it is the single biggest thing
that all of you are having to Grapple
with at home with your bills and we need
to get a grip of inflation and if we
don't do that now it's going to cost all
of you and everybody watching at home
far more in the long run and you know
what Liz your plans your own economic
advisor has said that that would lead to
mortgage rates interest rates going up
to seven percent can you imagine what
that's going to do for everyone here and
everyone watching that's thousands of
pounds on their mortgage bill is going
to tip millions of people into misery
and it's going to mean we absolutely
have no chance of winning the next
election either
uh let's hope for a more even temperate
exchange with our chief political
correspondent John Craig who is in stock
where the debate was just held good to
see you John um look do you have
something to wave around because I a bit
of paper I see the photos in your hand
we've got some polling data
we have indeed uh Neil yes it was fiery
it was uh feisty it was ferocious at
times but let me bring you some breaking
news yes an opinion poll this is a snap
poll this is by opinion researcher and
it's a snap debate poll tonight we asked
over 1 000 regular voters to watch the
debate and we've just asked them what
they who they thought performed best
results sunac 39 and Trust uh trust uh
38 so virtually neck and neck now that
represents a fight back by Rishi sunak
who has struggled in the early debates
and of course a Trails list trust badly
in opinion polls bookies odds and
surveys of conservative party members
what's changed we saw a much more
aggressive performance from Rishi soon
act tonight that's not to say that Liz
trust didn't fight strongly merely half
the one-hour debate was taken up by by
the key battleground of tax and spend
her argument I'll cut taxes now him
saying that it's irresponsible immoral
uh that those arguments we've heard at
times that got pretty Fierce they also
clashed on loyalty to Boris Johnson they
were personal questions as well about
Liz truss earrings and Rishi sunak's
expensive suits it all got quite uh
brighter passionate at times more more
lively and more bitter you might say
most of it than their previous two
debates they've taken part in but then
right at the end they started being nice
to each other and when Liz truss was
asked her if she'd have Rishi sunak in
her top team she said yes and he
appeared to say uh yes uh he'd happily
serve under her so she's the front
runner runner but we've seen Mr sunak
catching up an opinion poll tonight has
suggested on the performances here neck
and neck according to a poll